[Musica]
non so voi ma io non mi fido più di
nessuno
chiaramente non mi fido dei politici dei
giornalisti
neanche dei corrieri ogni volta che
compro qualcosa penso sempre che si
rubino i miei pacchi
non mi fidavo dei vaccini eppure mi sono
vaccinato solo perché mi fidavo ancora
meno dei novak si
no
non mi fido
dei preti ma meno delle suore
sapete che doveva venire qui una suora
appena saputo che c'era il mio nome ha
dato disdetta
non mi fido delle onlus senza scopo di
lucro
come no non mi fido dei miei ex e non mi
fiderò dei miei futuri ex a volte dubito
anche di mamma ciao mamma
chiaramente non mi fido neanche di voi
che ci fate qui chi vi paga per stare
qui ma chiaramente non sono l'unico non
sono solo sono in buona compagnia
pensate che secondo le ultime ricerche
il 64 per cento degli italiani non crede
più a nessuno non si fida più di nessuno
c'è fiducia
molta sfiducia
ma siamo giustificati
questo è quello che sta succedendo nel
mondo mentre sto parlando
guerra in ucraina
ma anche libia yemen palestina anche se
sono lontane da noi le guerre sono
comunque terribili
femminicidi uno ogni 72 ore
emergenza climatica
e quindi scioglimento dei ghiacciai
aumento assurdo delle temperature
incendi inondazioni
sperequazione sociale tra poveri e
ricchi
disuguaglianza fra donne e uomini
corruzione ed estremismo violento in
tutta l'africa
anche l'europa non sta messa benissimo
la gran bretagna se n'è andata
crisi di governo in italia
quella sempre e per concludere
criminalità organizzata molto più
organizzata di noi
e per concludere
zanzare
ma con tutti questi problemi che fanno
paura
come possiamo ancora fidarci del
prossimo
pensate infatti che solo il 19 per cento
degli italiani si fida ancora del suo
parlamento
pensate che più della metà degli
italiani non si fida più delle o ng
è ormai solo il 26 per cento delle
persone crede ancora alla pubblicità
ma se sempre meno persone
credono alla pubblicità tra poco sarò
disoccupato si la disoccupazione è un
altro problema
quindi se sempre meno persone credono
alla pubblicità qual è il futuro della
comunicazione
semplicemente non esiste
vorrei abolire la parola futuro
perché la comunicazione è già cambiata
oggi siamo arrivati alla relazione la
comunicazione è una trasmissione di un
messaggio
unidirezionale la relazione è una
condivisione di contenuti di idee è una
trasmissione di un messaggio
molti direzionale dove gli utenti
interagiscono
partecipano
diciamo che siamo passati da una
comunicazione che faceva sognare un
futuro migliore
ad una relazione che decreta la fine
delle illusioni
dopo 30 anni di puoi diventare l'uomo
più sexy d'italia con quella macchina e
poi diventare la donna più affascinante
con quel profumo
oppure potrai avere i capelli più
morbidi di un al paga con quello shampoo
e i denti più bianchi di un orso polare
con quel dentifricio
i sogni sono stati infranti
infatti non sono diventato l'uomo più
sexy d'italia
e nessuno mi contraddice bene grazie
oggi infatti cerchiamo autenticità
impegno
se nel marketing tradizionale
il centro dell'intera strategia era il
prodotto e le sue prestazioni
nel marketing relazionale il faro è
puntato su di noi su di voi e su di noi
è puntato sul consumatore sui suoi
desideri sulle sue aspirazioni sui suoi
bisogni ma soprattutto sui suoi problemi
che poi sono anche i nostri
il consumatore è diventato più
consapevole non chiediamo alle imprese
nuovi miracolosi prodotti chiediamo
impegno chiediamo che
possano risolvere i nostri problemi o
perlomeno tentare
di non aggravarli
pensate che le imprese possono molto
perché il 75 per cento per cento delle
persone nel mondo crede ancora al suo
datore di lavoro è forse l'unica
istituzione
che non risente della crisi di fiducia
diciamo che crediamo nel nostro datore
di lavoro perché forse l'unico che non
ci chiede soldi anzi ce li dà quasi
tutti
quindi oggi gli amministratori delle
aziende
hanno un'opportunità
ma non hanno più scelta anche se i
consumatori vogliono impegno e azione
loro devono darglielo non basta più
quindi
dichiararsi
responsabili non basta più mostrarsi
e raccontarsi
oggi
oggi bisogna
mostrarsi
e quindi ciò mi mostrami quello che fai
per sensibilizzare per promuovere un
cambiamento
per risolvere un problema che preoccupa
tutti don gelmini non raccontarmelo e
basta
agisci
in parole più semplici
non dirmi che mi ami non dirmi che ci
tieni a me
se poi mi tratti male prenditi cura di
me questo è brand activism
[Applauso]
cosa fanno oggi i brand più progressisti
i brand più amati per risolvere i sette
meravigliosi problemi del mondo li
conoscete
il primo è il cambiamento climatico
il secondo le migrazioni
il terzo la disuguaglianza
imperante il tè il quarto la
sovrappopolazione
la mancanza di istruzione
l'estremismo
e la corruzione
c'è per esempio nike che protesta contro
la polizia
perché tutti i giorni lotta contro la
comunità afroamericana e nike come
s'impegna sceglie proprio il testimonial
sportivo simbolo di questa protesta
c'è airbnb che annulla i costi di
servizio per accogliere i rifugiati
ucraini perché la mission di airbnb e di
far sentire tutti a casa
c'è patagonia
investe tantissimo tempo e risorse e
progetti
e arriva al punto di dirti non compra un
altro giacchetto questa è sostenibilità
c'è dub che lotta da anni per una
bellezza autentica normale senza filtri
st graham per aumentare la nostra
autostima
e con rocchetta invece abbiamo fatto un
progetto autonomia per le donne dalla
parte delle donne per davvero per
aiutarle ad uscire dalla violenza
domestica
con tappo cerchiamo di seppellire
omofobia e quindi scendiamo in strada a
manifestare sventolando bari arcobaleno
e lo facciamo per davvero
è questo che le persone oggi vogliono
soprattutto i giovani vogliono che le
imprese guidino il cambiamento
non basta più quindi vendere prodotti e
pubblicizzare servizi oggi le persone
ammirano le aziende che si occupano di
temi sociali politici e culturali a
costo di dividere l'opinione pubblica a
costo anche di perdere i clienti
la pubblicità quindi si è arricchita di
significato e di coraggio
le imprese con le loro azioni possono
davvero lasciare il segno e dominare il
futuro
vendere e massimizzare non è più lo
scopo principale ma è il risultato
dell'impegno che le aziende mettono nel
creare una community online ed offline
di persone con dei valori condivisi che
collaborano insieme ai brand per
risolvere i grandi problemi del mondo
acquisto dopo acquisto scontrino dopo
scontrino per
recuperare quella fiducia che abbiamo
perso
grazie
[Applauso]